But why does the post condition of square root fail? The answer is simple, yet not so simple.
What we lack here is diagnostic information.
We don't know the values of r or z or anything that happens in between.
So what we do is, we set up a framework that allows us to access these.
So what we have set here is we have set up a try except block around the square root function,
which catches the assertion and when an assertion is being raised,
or any other kind of error is being raised, we print out the offending parameter r
and we exit the loop, so let's see what happens here if we invoke the whole thing.
So here's the bad value, 8*436.9207865. Wow, magic value.
So why can't we just square this. What's wrong here.
So we print out the value and now we go
and actually square the square root and multiply it by itself.
Let's see what we got--again, we run the whole thing and 2123.01753488
and this is 2123.01753488.
Well, by all means and measures, these two look identical to me.
Why does the assertion above it failed.
We can solve the mystery simply by looking at the actual difference between these two values.
Let's see what the numerical difference is between
the square root, square, and original value itself.
Here comes another value which fails 9,049. something and here at the very end,
you see the difference--it's 10^-12, meaning that 12 digits after the comma
we do have a difference between r and the √r²
The reason why this assertion failed is simply a rounding error,
the numbers are the same up to the 11th digit.
At the 12th digit, they actually are different and this is why the assertion failed.